on his 12th birthday today
we passed the george floyd justice and
policing act
30 years after the world saw
the brutal beating of rodney king
i was in los angeles at the time and i
remember
when that video was released i thought
that was going to be the moment
that policing was transformed in the
united states
because finally the world would see
what had been happening in black
communities for over a century
but there was never a way to document it
and so the story was always the same
the person went for a gun i was afraid
i didn't know what was going to happen
that was the reason for the beating or
the shooting
after rodney king's brutal beating
nothing fundamentally changed in the
country
years later we had cell phone cameras
and now we have seen
video after video after video of people
being beat
and people being killed that is the
reason
for the george floyd justice and
policing act two measures of the bill
hold police officers accountable and
then other measures of the bill
support raising the standards and
accreditation process of policing
in the united states i know that change
is difficult
but i believe fundamentally that police
officers don't want to work
in an environment where the culture says
if they are to step up if they are to
say anything
if an officer is abusive or as an
officer is corrupt
then their very lives could be in danger
so one of the goals of the george floyd
justice and policing act
is to raise the standards of policing in
america
and also to transform the culture
i am happy to say that we passed this
bill
in an environment where our country is
looking at a racial reckoning
we have a president who in his
inauguration speech
talked about ending racial inequities
he made a commitment to that and he made
a commitment to the transformation of
policing
in the united states so i am happy that
we were able to do this today
i am confident that we will be able to
work
with the senate and that we will put the
george floyd justice and policing act
on president biden's death let me just
say
that we could not have accomplished
anything without outstanding leadership
in the house of representatives and we
are fortunate to have
the most powerful woman in the house of
representatives
speaker nancy pelosi who was absolutely
adamant
that we accomplished this last year that
we make a contribution to transforming
policing
in the united states and it's my honor
to bring up
speaker nancy pelosi
thank you very much madam chair karen
bass has been a relentless champion
for justice in america she
saw the challenge that we are facing
and she said there has to be justice in
policing
she put together the legislation working
together with members of the judiciary
committee
on what she serves working with the
distinguished uh
she doesn't serve she does serve yes
she serves on so many so many chairs of
so many things the
foreign affairs committee but working
with the distinguished chair
mr nadler whom i would be pleased to
yield to in just a moment but not before
acknowledging us karen best as in
certain landmark dates
nearly one year ago george floyd
gasped his last words i can't
breathe and ignited a nationwide
reckoning on the racial injustice and
police brutality
that exists in our country i can't
breathe
since then americans from every corner
of the country and actually people
throughout the world
have taken to the streets to peacefully
protest
violence against black americans yet
despite
these protests violence continues
we cannot accept this epic epidemic
of injustice which is why we will pass
and send well we have passed
now we have passed and sent to the
senate and to present
the president the george floyd justice
in policing act
so it can become the law of the land
we're proud of this legislation which
will fundamentally
transform the culture with bold
unprecedented reforms
some of which the distinguished chair
chairman bass
mentioned it will not erase centuries of
systemic racism and extend
excessive policing and it will not bring
back
george floyd briona taylor
say her name briona taylor amman arbory
or the countless others who have been
killed or harmed
but it will take a tremendous step
forward to stop the violence stem the
suffering
and start to build a better america
we all have respect for our men and
women in blue
who serve our country uh protecting
all of us uh said on the floor many of
them leave home
uh to risk their lives to save lives to
protect
to provide perfect protection in our
community
overwhelmingly they are not part of this
culture
of violence against african americans
but nonetheless
our respect for them cannot turn into
apathy
against what we know is happening and
that must be stopped
it must be stopped our colleague
madeline dean
when she was on four she talked about i
can't breathe
and how george floyd called out for his
mother
mother his mother any mother
in the country who heard that had to be
so impacted by it
i said on the floor that uh i think of
george floyd all the time
even when i'm not thinking in terms of
this injustice
even when i'm washing my hands and they
say wash your hands
for 20 seconds in terms of covet so that
your hands are thoroughly
washed and i think i can't do that for
20 seconds it's taking too much
time
eight minutes and 46 seconds
of intentional knee to the neck
a public lynching an assassination
before our very eyes so i said to the
family when they asked
madam speaker will you name the bill for
george i said only if you think the bill
is worthy
of that and they said it was and they
were very
pleased that we passed it then even more
pleased when we pass it now
uh because we have a president in the
white house who shares
our values of liberty and justice and
with that
a person committed to liberty and
justice rule uh
and particularly in the form of this
legislation
uh the distinguished chair of the
judiciary committee jerry knabber
of new york well thank you very much
madam speaker
i want to begin by thanking karen best a
distinguished member of the judiciary
committee
and most recent chair of the
congressional black caucus
for her her work in crafting the george
floyd
justice and policing act and sheila
jackson lee the chair of the crime
subcommittee for her work last year
and then helping to bring this bill to
the floor in this congress
and of course i want to speak thank the
speaker and the rest of the democratic
leadership for their unwavering support
of this vital legislation the house
first considered the george floyd
justice and policing act last summer
when the streets were flooded with
americans demanding fundamental change
in the culture of law enforcement and
meaningful accountability for officers
who commit misconduct unfortunately
although the house acted swiftly with
legislation to meet the moment
the then republican-led senate failed to
act
but even if some believe the national
conversation has moved on since last
summer's events
the need to act is just as urgent today
it no longer makes headlines but every
day too many people
disproportionately black latinx and
indigenous people
people living in poverty and people with
disabilities face harassment and
sometimes violence
at the hands of too many law enforcement
officers
i am proud of all the work that has gone
into crafting this legislation
which takes a comprehensive and
thoughtful approach to a very complex
issue
i'm also pleased to see the wide and
growing support behind this legislation
from leading civil rights and social
justice groups to law enforcement
associations
companies business associations and many
many more
last year i was honored to invite
philanese floyd
george floyd's brother to testify before
the judiciary committee
he told us of the pain he felt watching
the video of his brother
being killed by a minneapolis police
officer
he gave voice to the pain that the
entire nation felt
he also spoke to the anger of knowing
that george floyd was only the latest
in a much too long list of victims of
police misconduct
disproportionately people of color he
spoke to the frustration
that time and again in the face of
overwhelming evidence that dramatic
reform is needed
congress has done very little mr floyd
charged us with making sure that the
death of his brother
and other victims of police violence
would not be in vain
and he pleaded with us to turn that pain
and anger that we all feel
into meaningful change his words echoed
the voices of millions of americans
who demand justice and demand action
today we answer their call and as we
answer their call
i want to comment on a few of the
uh contentions of the republicans in
opposing this bill
they say that it would defund the police
no it wouldn't
it will clearly not defund the police
that is not the intent of the bill nor
the effect of it
all you have to do is read it secondly
they say they're very upset
at the repeal of qualified immunity in
the bill
but you know qualified immunity and they
talk as if
revealing qualified immunity would make
the police
um victims of of all kinds of things
but the fact is that qualified immunity
is a judge-made
doctrine 40 years ago you didn't have it
judicial qualified immunity was invented
by the courts
only in the last 40 years and 40 years
ago
you had the same problems but you didn't
have police officers
being drawn and courted or losing their
homes
and all these other things that the
republicans
would make you fear so the legislation
is very carefully drafted
it's timely it's for the moment
and it is very very necessary and i
thank
the uh um i thank the leadership of the
house
for um for supporting this bill
the honor to introduce uh the majority
leader of the house
mr hoyer who has been instrumental in
supporting this legislation and so many
other good things
thank you very much i want to
congratulate karen bale karen bass as
you know is the former speaker of the
california assembly
an extraordinarily talented legislator
and a
legislator who works not only
among her colleagues but across the
aisle in a very constructive way and i
am confident
that with karen bass's leadership we're
going to pass it through the united
states senate
working with republicans and democrats
speaker bass
i know you're going to get that done and
i'm looking forward to that day
uh i remember as we all remember
that eight minutes and 46 seconds
but i'm old enough to also remember
rodney king
and although there were not cell phones
somebody did take
a moving picture of it a video
a man lying on the ground helpless
the batons swinging swinging
swinging
and in the final analysis no
accountability
that's not america
speaker pelosi mentioned a lynching and
you may have said no he wasn't hung
very frankly when i was told some two
years ago
that we hadn't passed an andy lynching
statute
i was amazed and i went to karen karen
was then chairman
and i said why hadn't we passed an andy
lynching
and we started working on it and we
passed it and we kept
included it in this bill as well for
your
for your uh i needed to look it up in
the dictionary
lynching is the taking of a life without
legal sanction
not necessarily a hanging
it's famous famously done over and over
and over
by hanging by throwing a rope over a
tree limb
and lifting somebody up letting them
hang there until
dead
that's not america and this bill
speaks to the values of america
that we cannot take lives without
cause without legal justification
because we honor life
a lot of people who didn't vote for this
bill didn't honor life
in that vote i
was pleased along with the speaker to
bring the house back on june 25th
which was about uh what was the date if
floyd was killed
[Music]
may 25th so just about exactly a month
after 30 days
karen bass worked for may 26 along with
the congressional black caucus along
with mr nadler
along with others to put a bill together
that would respond
not a year later not two years later not
forget about it
and we brought everybody back a little
early
on the 25th and passed that bill and
sent it to the senate
sadly like so many bills we sent we sent
to the senate
nothing happened there was a bill that
they came up with
they put on the floor it didn't pass and
they didn't work
we're going to work karen best going to
work across the aisle
we want this bill to be law this is not
a message
bill this is a bill to change
conduct to make it so that black mothers
don't have to be talking to black sons
on how to act and how to stay out of
trouble
i'm pleased to be a sponsor of this bill
i spoke strongly for it on the floor
i'm glad it passed it was unless that
vote was changed it was a bipartisan
vote
we got one republican did they stick
the last time they stuck um
so we will now go from here
and we will see that bill go to the
senate
and i will urge chuck summer schumer uh
to
and and dick durbin the chairman of the
committee
to make this a priority and i know that
speaker bass is working with senator
scott
before this and is going to continue to
work with him and appeal to his
knowledge of history and of fairness
so that we can pass this bill now i'm
pleased to
and uh mr clyburn's not here but the
chairwoman
of the congressional black caucus a dear
friend of mine
i called her the joyce petey from
the ohio state george payne thank you
denny where are you first of all let me
just say
what an honor it is to stand here
tonight with our leadership speaker
pelosi
but to you madam congresswoman
candace thank you for your leadership
and your partnership
because that's what the message is we're
sending tonight
the partnership between our leadership
the congressional black caucus and the
judiciary committee
you have heard and you will hear
eight minutes 46 seconds
i can't breathe a knee
on my neck whether we say
george floyd brianna taylor
or from my district casey goodson andre
hill
or tamir rice that is what i want you to
remember
why we fought so hard
to get this bill right and why we are so
proud to stand here tonight we cannot
bring back
their loss or the pain their families
and friends
have faced but we can fight for
transparency
for accountability for justice
and let me just say as i stood with some
of my colleagues
with george floyd's family tonight
we do this in remembrance
in honor of him and all those who have
lost their lives
senselessly at the hands of law
enforcement
but i want you to remember no matter
what anyone says
this deal is about justice
transparency accountability
and lastly in the words of his
seven-year-old daughter
when she said my daddy
has changed the world tonight i say
as chair of the congressional black
caucus
we stand with our colleagues as we
change the world and that is
our power our message thank you
and now we will hear from the chairwoman
of the
subcommittee on judiciary crime and
terrorism
representative sheila jackson lee
thank you very much congresswoman bass
and thank you
for your leadership uh thank you to our
leaders and as well the congressional
black caucus we worked as a team
and the judiciary committee worked as a
team
let me say that this was so important to
the floyd family
that they wanted to be present
to be able to see the fruition
if you will of the sacrifice
of their brother for he was sacrificed
in a calculated
killing murder on the streets of america
a murder that evidenced itself around
the world
with a grin a smirk on the actor
the police officer that was causing his
death
and causing the words i can't breathe
and so i want to say to his late parents
who
his mother who i got to
uh engage in in our congressional
district
where they grew up cecinia jones floyd
his late mother their late mother their
late father george perry floyd
and of course the beautiful daughter who
acknowledged
that her daddy was a tree shaker
and one who could be a mountain climber
his siblings felonious floyd zaza
williams latonya floyd
rodney floyd bridget floyd terrace floyd
and his nephew brandon williams
we do this in their name and the names
of all of the families
who have lost loved ones violently
without charges even allegations
but fell to their death at the hands of
those who were to protect and serve
let me clearly say that on the day of
insurrection
none of us ignored the bravery of police
officers
i will not accept the attack on those
who support george floyd's
justice and policing act that we are
against police
we honor those who stand to defend
we honor those who have gone ahead
to the bravery of supporting
and defending those who need that and
then those who are engaged
and misconduct that is who this bill
addresses the tragic death of george
floyd has awakened the world
and the nation to the gross injustice
that too many african-americans face on
a daily basis
i want to add to the fact of the
naysayers that qualified immunity and
its removal thereof
will hurt police absolutely not i'll
give you a simple expression of what it
is
the qualified immunity that is a fixture
and a
made-up concept of courts not a
statutory concept
all it does as it is modified is to open
the door of justice
not only for police who can walk through
it but for victims who can walk through
it
that is all that we do in this bill it
doesn't diminish
any officer's ability to serve in fact
enhances the ability to serve because
then they begin to look at those that
they're protecting
in an equal manner that each of them
will have a right
to go into court so what is the george
floyd justice and policing act
what is the evidence of righteous
protesters across the world
millions who stood in line to march to
support this bill
and it is a transformational and bold
reform
on policing practices it is the civil
rights law of policing so with our vote
today
we're saying that black lives matter
we're saying that america matters
and we're making a difference i believe
that this bill will find a home in the
united states senate
and it will pass finally let us be
reminded as we have all said
8 minutes and 46 seconds terrifying
unspeakable feeling that you could not
breathe and no one would listen to you
and having your life
sucked from you on the streets of
america
no one to comfort you no way to say
goodbye
no way to get up no way to have
relief no officer that was there
intervened to stop this individual with
a smirk on their face
from doing the wrong thing and so i just
want to
conclude by saying that the effective
enforcement
of the law and administration of justice
requires that the confidence in the
community
is equal to the confidence in the law
we must have confidence in the law of
george floyd justice and policing act
does that it does it now it's time to
pass it
we will pass it in the united states
senate and we will get it signed by the
president of the united states
and finally let me introduce our essene
chair
of the democratic caucus and let me
congratulate him for
an incredible two days issues conference
that we just had
representative chairman hakeem jeffries
well thank you so much and let me just
uh congratulate karen bass and thank her
on her tremendous leadership
in leading the charge and shepherding
this incredibly
important effort forward and for your
thoughtfulness
uh for your intellectual firepower for
your consensus building efforts
uh that will only continue to make sure
that this bill
gets over the finish line the george
floyd justice in policing
act is about accountability the george
floyd justice and policing act is about
liberty
and justice for all the george floyd
justice and policing act is about equal
protection
under the law the george floyd jefferson
policing act is about making sure
that every single american regardless of
race
can experience life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness the george floyd
justice and policing act
is about continuing america's long
necessary and majestic
march toward a more perfect union
thank you so much mr chairman i believe
we have to go for
our vote uh if there's one or two
questions can you tell me if they're on
the mtr or if they're on final passage
okay did you guys vote already for mtr
okay yeah i did but can you stay for a
minute
go ahead thank you i want to know what
your discussions are like
negotiations with senator scott
congressman what leader lawyer mentioned
and then what group how what agreement
how do you think you can work with
republicans what ground can you
find and then what is a little bit tough
well you know i won't tell you about my
negotiations with tim scott but i will
tell you that uh we have been in
conversation
what happened after we passed the bill
the last time
is a group of us a bipartisan group of
us many uh whom were problem solvers
started meeting
and started looking for potential areas
of agreement because many of our
republican colleagues said
they thought they could get to yes on
this but they had some difficulties
one of the things that has happened in
the last 12 months though
is that many states moved ahead without
us and they started passing reforms
so this time when we sit down to meet we
can talk about reforms that are already
in place such as
in colorado qualified immunity has been
uh reformed i spoke to governor polis
our former
colleagues so we have a lot of basis in
which to begin discussions and that's
what we plan to do
yes
oh yeah okay so just you know as you
go to reach out to republicans
particularly how harvested the united
states senate has become
with the goal of kinnington republican
vote how do you make that case
i think the case will be made here with
a bipartisan group of legislators that
will then take it to
the uh the senate and again my
conversations never stopped with
tim scott so and my republican
colleagues understood we were doing it
this way the only other way to do it
is to go through regular order and that
would be very counterproductive
and so we did not choose that route so i
spoke to them
they weren't happy about the process
that we used they understood it
our relationships are still fine and so
i think that we'll be okay to have the
conversations
sure briefly and i'll step away um
in spite of what is perceived to be a
contentious
senate and one would say it's a
contentious house we just passed it in
the house
i do think there is a pathway to pass it
because we have already a widespread
evidentiary pathway
we've had more killings we've shown
police misconduct
i believe republicans in the senate and
democrats want to do the right thing
i think the qualified immunity can uh
become uh not an obstacle when you
explain it that it is not taking away
rights
it is simply opening the door for
expanded rights
the transparency the accountability
should not be anything that republicans
are opposed to
i'll be joining the congresswoman in
collaborating helping um trying to reach
out to those
that i may know um in particular to be
able to say
uh that this is not a harmful bill it is
in fact
a bill that simply enforces better
community
police relationships not orientation
but relationships who would not want to
improve the opportunity
for police to do their job it uplifts
accreditation it encourages police
officers
to secure their higher degrees
so i think we have something to offer to
the senate and they might just buy it i
think they will
oh well thank you uh let me acknowledge
that representative barbara lee was here
representative lisa blunt rochester and
representative brenda lawrence but they
uh had to leave to go vote yesterday
well i certainly hope that it doesn't
come to that i do hope that on the major
initiatives that we need to pass through
the house
such as the rescue act well the rescue
act that will probably
be partisan but i am hoping that my
republican colleagues uh
come around because there's so much that
needs to be done uh in the country so i
hope that it doesn't come to that
it might i hope it doesn't
well you know i mean i think all of us
might have our own individual lines in
the sand
but um you know i couldn't tell you if
this policy doesn't pass then that's the
line in the sand for me
it's fine for it to be the line in the
sand for me but i'm over here in the
house
i i don't get to participate in that
particular decision
and then it's nice to say that when
you're in power but you
just you just described that we're
guaranteed two years we're not
guaranteed any more than that
so we make a change like that and then
what happens so i'm certainly hoping
that in the midterm
we defy history and we actually pick up
seats
but uh who knows okay well
i mean i think that it was easier for us
to just go ahead and get all of our
business done
as you know tomorrow begins the
republican issues conference and so
i think that there were a multitude of
reasons but i do
have to acknowledge the fact that many
of my colleagues
and staff and maybe even some of you
who were there during the insurrection
people are deeply concerned about what
uh
potential threats could be out there and
it's not just threats
here but it's us coming here it's we all
live
out in the community and so you have
heard already from the capitol police
that threats are up
90 to members of the house so i think
it's reasonable that we just went ahead
and finished our work
last question
no actually it didn't i don't think it
came to play but i do want to say
something about january 6
and the relationship between this bill
and that
for generations black people have been
trying to raise the issue
that white supremacy is a problem in
some police departments
and in the los angeles area for example
in our sheriff's department
every few years we have a problem with
organized gangs
sheriffs that become gang members that
start their own gangs
tattoos the whole nine yards and those
gangs are typically white supreme
gangs and so for the first time i think
now
we're going to look at that look at
white supremacists whether individuals
or organized elements
not just in law enforcement but also in
the military
it's just to me it was a rodney king
moment there was a videotape
that revealed what we had been trying to
say for a hundred years
and there was an insurrection that
exposed what we have been suffering from
for so many years thank you very much
you